it's time to go to hell because Diablo 4
is almost here arriving more than a
decade since the last Mainline game in
this series first announced all the way
back in 2019 Blizzard's return to the
world of sanctuary is aiming to be a
darker and grittier game than its
predecessor since its initial reveal the
company has shared a lot of details on
the game its classes locations held
several betas and joined forces with KFC
to help promote its arrival with some
strange menu choices here is everything
we know about Diablo 4 so far
Diablo 4's story is said to be a darker
tale than we saw in Diablo 3 as blizzard
has described the game's storyline as
its most tragic tale yet like the prior
games this latest release takes place in
sanctuary a world conceived by the angel
inarius and demon Lilith both of who
became disillusioned with the Eternal
War raged by the High Heavens and
burning hells and wish to create a Haven
for both angels and demons that were
looking to escape the conflict the pair
created Sanctuary by stealing a powerful
artifact known as the world Stone which
was then used to hide the Refuge from
both Heaven and Hell soon after
relations between the Angels and Demons
on Sanctuary gave literal birth to a new
race the Nephilim retaining powers from
both factions the Nephilim were
incredibly powerful with angels and
demons fearing that they could
ultimately surpass them many among their
ranks wish to eradicate the Nephilim but
inarius stayed their hand Lilith however
concerned for the newly formed race that
she considered to be her children went
on a murderous Rampage slaying many in
sanctuary that had ill intent toward the
Nephilim as such inario's banished
Lilith from sanctuary and began to
tamper with the world Stone in order to
diminish the power of the Nephilim over
the centuries and Millennia that passed
the debuffed Nephilim evolved into the
Mortal race of humanity inarias is
meddling with the worldstone also lifted
the veil on Sanctuary allowing it to be
discovered by both the High Heavens and
burning Hells needless to say in the
time since its formation things have not
gone according to plan on the planet
with Sanctuary descending into chaos
consistently torn apart by War and
bloodshed Diablo IV is set several
decades after the events of Diablo III's
Reba of souls expansion in which
Humanity was almost wiped out by the
Archangel malthail in the power vacuum
that is formed since a cult devoted to
Lilith manages to release the demon from
the dimension she was banished to
returning to sanctuary and looking to
reshape It In Her Image as you can
imagine inarias and his church of light
will be having none of that thus setting
the stage for the conflict in which the
player character will play a pivotal
role in
the player character in Diablo 4 is a
Wanderer simply looking to survive the
now harsh world that is sanctuary at the
start of the game the player can choose
from one of five classes that will
dictate the abilities and type of
gameplay available to them when compared
to previous Diablo games the classes of
Diablo 4 will be far more customizable
allowing for a deeper focus on build
management and designing the look of
your chosen archetype on their Journey
the Barbarian class is your traditional
heavy melee class in Diablo 4 with
two-handed weapons delivering massive
blows and dual wield weapons offering
quicker strikes this class features an
Arsenal system for weapon slots so you
can switch between up to four weapons on
the Fly and attacks like Dash strikes
and war cries allow you to control enemy
clusters and keep others safe the Druid
is a nature wielding shapeshifter who is
capable of taking many different forms
depending on the situation these include
both a bear and a wolf and The Druids
can even change forms mid attack for
more complex strategies the Earth Wind
and storm are all under a druid's
control making for an Eclectic mix of
abilities
returning from Diablo 3's DLC The
Necromancer class is as the name
suggests capable of conjuring an undead
Army three death-focused bastions bone
blood and Shadow are all at a
necromancer's disposal along with your
skeleton army you'll also be able to
wield a scythe the classic weapon of any
self-respecting Grim Reaper a classic
Mage style class the sorcerer able to
harness several different elements to
deal damage these include ice lightning
and fire which should provide them with
plenty of options against sanctuaries
varied enemies they can even turn into a
ball of lightning and shoot across the
map if you liked the Demon Hunter in
Diablo 3 and were disappointed to see it
missing in Diablo 4 then the returning
Diablo 1 Rogue class is for you this
class uses short swords and Bows as well
as speed focused and stealth-focused
moves Rogues excel in both close range
and long-range combat and you can also
apply shadow all poison effects to deal
extra damage in the middle of your
Speedy flashy combos
Diablo 4 isn't straying far from its
roots as an isometric dungeon calling
action RPG the Diablo series is built
around the loot and gear grind as you
level up from fighting hordes of enemies
and tough bosses and there's now more
options for you to acquire more Loot and
descend in power as stated previously
Diablo 4 is now an open world action RPG
allowing for more freedom to explore and
more opportunities to engage in new
activities along with main quests you
can also find events happening in the
world allowing you to sync up with other
players to take down large targets or
Raid dangerous dungeons as such Diablo 4
isn't structured linearly like Diablo 3
there are five different regions that
make up Diablo 4 Sanctuary setting the
snowy fractured Peaks the dry steps
desert the how is the swamps the
skosglen coastal forests and the ruins
of Kazakhstan overall the world is
bigger than all previous Diablo Maps
combined some of the standout features
that have been announced off a Diablo 4
PVP battles mounts for faster traversal
and the return of Rune Words which will
be included in a post-watch update
previously featured in Diablo 2 Rune
words are the way to tune your character
and further tweak how they function
attaching them grants different effects
and Stat Buffs all classes also have
skill ranks and challenge trees that
you'll progress through as you level up
skills and talent trees will be vast for
each class and blizzard said the players
will only have around 40 percent of
skills unlocked by the time they reach
the end game Diablo 4 will be an always
online game in a persistent world shared
with other players even for those who
wish to go about things as a solo
experience however multiplayer is a big
factor in the Diablo experience enemies
will scale to the party's levels and
dungeons will be separate instances with
various difficulty options this also
extends to the new PVP gameplay with the
fields of hatred in these zones players
can fight for loot against more
challenging monsters and escape with
your hall to keep it in similar fashion
to the division's dark zones it Blends
PVE with PVP as players earn Paragon
points they'll be able to unlock more
tiles on the Paragon board there are
several types of tiles ranging from
normal to Legendary with only one of the
latter available on each board there are
also sockets tiles with a special glyphs
as well as a single glyph tile you can
use to unlock a second Paragon board
connected to the first similar to Diablo
3's challenging Rift system Diablo 4
will feature nightmare dungeons these
are essentially deadlier remixes of
Diablo 4's standard dungeons of which
the game will have more than 120 and any
of them can be converted into a
nightmare dungeon using a nightmare
sigil this adds more difficult monsters
different objectives and various
mutators to change up the experience the
best rewards will come from playing on
higher World tier difficulties which can
be unlocked once the campaign has been
completed and Capstone dungeons have
been conquered if you're looking to
build the best possible characters some
farming will be in order fortunately
Diablo 4's endgame hell Tides will allow
for Target farming of specific item
slots this end game activity will let
players seek out loot caches within
these areas and slaying monsters and
health hides will earn you Cinders that
can be used to unlock the caches
[Applause]
[Music]
Diablo 4 is set to release on June 6
2023 for 70
pre-ordering connect you Cosmetics for
other blizzard games including the
inaris wings and Daenerys murloc pet in
Diablo 3 amalgam of Rage Mountain World
of Warcraft and the umber winged
Darkness Cosmetics set in Diablo
Immortal stepping up to the game's 90
digital only deluxe edition you'll get
the Temptation Mount and hellborn
carapace mount armor for use in the game
the deluxe edition will also include the
game's season 1 battle pass and allow
players to boot up the game as early as
June 1st in the Americas and June 2nd in
Europe and Asia for 100 blizzard is
selling the game's digital only Ultimate
Edition which includes 20 Level skips on
its season 1 battle pass as well as an
in-game wings of the Creator emote and
that's everything we know about Diablo 4
ahead of its release whether you're
returning to Sanctuary or it's your
first time in the hellish World the game
looks to be a bloody good time make sure
to like And subscribe to Gamespot for
even more coverage on Diablo 4.
[Music]